PENSION IS EXPECTED AT ANY TIME.
>> Bret: IT IS FRIDAY
AFTERNOON, WE WILL WATCH FOR ANY
RELEASES.
THANK YOU.
IS THE ADULT MOVIE STAR WHO SAYS
SHE HAD AN AFFAIR WITH
DONALD TRUMP IN DANGER?
HER LOYAL SO, SO THAT SHE HAS
BEEN PHYSICALLY THREATENED AND I
BEEN PHYSICALLY THREATENED AND S
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLP
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLO
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLI
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLE
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLD
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLT
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLI
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILLS
SAYING THAT STORMY DANIELS WILL.
THAT PROMPTED A RELUCTANT
RESPONSE FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THIS AFTERNOON.
HERE THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT,
FOR THAT STORY AND MORE.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET, I
ACKNOWLEDGE A GREAT NUMBER OF
AMERICANS DO NOT WANT TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT THE STORMY DEMOS
CONTROVERSY, BUT EVEN THE
WHITE HOUSE CANNOT HELP BUT
WEIGH IN ON THE LATEST TWIST OF
WEIGH IN ON THE LATEST TWIST OFH
WEIGH IN ON THE LATEST TWIST OFE
DRAMA.
>> TRY THOUGH THEY MIGHT TO STAY
CLEAR OF THE SUBJECT,
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS WERE AGAIN
FORCED AWAY INTO THE LATEST
CONTROVERSIES FOLLOWING STORMY
DANIELS.
WHOSE ATTORNEY CLAIMS WAS
PHYSICALLY THREATENED TO KEEP
QUIET ABOUT THE ALLEGED
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEN PRIVATE
CITIZEN TRUMP.
>> OBVIOUSLY WE TAKE THIS
INSECURITY OF ANY PERSON
SERIOUSLY, CERTAINLY WOULD
CONDEMN ANYONE THREATENING ANY
INDIVIDUAL, BUT I HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT SITUATION.
I WOULD REFER YOU TO THE
PRESIDENT'S OUTSIDE PERSONAL
ATTORNEY.
>> BUT DANIELS ATTORNEY PROMISED
THE WORLD WOULD KNOW MORE ABOUT
THE ALLEGED THREAT SOON.
>> I AM NOT ALLEGING ANYTHING, I
AM STATING A FACT.
THE FACT IS THAT MY CLIENT WAS
PHYSICALLY THREATENED TO STAY
SILENT ABOUT WHAT SHE KNEW ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
THE DETAILS SURROUNDING THAT,
SHE IS GOING TO DISCUSS I'M SURE
ON THE 60 MINUTE INTERVIEW ON
MARCH 25.
>> FOR THE CONTROVERSY DUSTING
TO THE BLIZZARD OF NEWS
SURROUNDING THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER H.R.
McMASTER.
THE WHITE HOUSE PUSH BACK
AGAINST THAT.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT IT
WAS NOT ACCURATE AND THAT HE HAS
NO INTENTION OF CHANGING, THAT
THEY HAD A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP AND HE LOOKED
FORWARD WORKING WITH THEM.
>> FOR NOW McMASTER JOINTS
IT -- STAYS ON THE JOB, BUT THE
CABINET COULD REFUSE THE NOMINEE
THE HEAD OF THE CIA, GINA
MESKILL WHO MORE THAN A DECADE
AGO OVERSAW AN INFAMOUS CIA
PRISON IN THAILAND WHERE
TERRORISM SUSPECTS WERE WATER
BOARDED.
>> WE ARE HIGHLY CONFIDENT AND
CERTAINLY VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
NOMINATION OF DEPUTY DIRECTOR TO
TAKE OVER AT THE CIA.
SHE IS INCREDIBLY QUALIFIED,
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN IN THE CIA
FOR OVER 30 YEARS, HAS THE
RESPECT OF BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
>> BY THE WAY GOT TO THAT POST
WELL AFTER THE WATERBOARDING
TOOK PLACE AS FAR AS WE CAN TELL
FROM OUR REPORTING.
RAND PAUL, THE SENATOR FROM
KENTUCKY HAS COME OUT AGAINST
HER NOMINATION.
BUT TODAY THE WHITE HOUSE
PUSHBACK ON THAT SAYING THAT HIS